[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous pouvez le voir nous
sommes à la fête dès l'âge 360 neuvième
édition cette année 150 attractions et
des dizaines de restaurants ici sur ce
site alors michael je propose qu'on ce
défi un défi oui et je te propose comme
premier défi le train fantôme j'adore ça
je connais si on va voir si c'est le cas
alors moi de mon côté je te défie sur
l'une des nouvelles attractions du 6 et
le bateau pirate il est orange et yb a
trait aux
allées
[Musique]
et ça y est le train fantôme 1
ce suspect
ça commence très fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
map
ça va
[Musique]
je suis pas du tout rassuré mais bon
hahaha
un peu plus voilà ceux ci dément célia
je t'aime pas du tout
voilà
trois
allers
on a battu tous nous voilà
[Musique]
à la commande à plusieurs tout doucement
ça va mieux comme ça en fait je préfère
le niveau ou de niveau que
[Musique]
bon bah c'est terminé tu as michael
c'était simple finalement
[Musique]
bravo desquels brocélia un partout à
part si vous palau santé je crois qu'on
peut passer à l'étape supérieure super
gars on va faire une des plus grandes
attractions de la ba oui on y va et
s'est envolé sur l'extrême sud extrême
ou la wii c'est que la peña
[Musique]
ma michael tu es où
pour palier
[Musique]
c'est pas si simple que ça en les petits
canards
[Musique]
rappeler encore
et voilà
c'est
olivier gasnier
[Musique]
il ya enfin une activité qui va nous
rassembler ici à saint jean le oui on va
bien se régaler et ses amis l'eau on est
dans un des restaurants incontournable
de la scène dès l'âge et alors au menu
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de belles
choses à coups de botte choisir
notamment du jarret avec des frites ça a
l'air très appétissants toi ces liens tu
as mangé un petit mix de plusieurs
rondes et ce choix que tu vas faire
chauffer sur cette pierre et le
cameraman le goût romantique juste
derrière la caméra par angers le
porcelet c'est vraiment notre tourneur
ici exactement ce qu'il faut manger ce
et cce sérpahin seniors exactement et
c'est à découvrir ici à la fête des
loges à saint-germain-en-laye jusqu'au
15 août
[Musique]